偏差はダめ。人間性が低い。人のことを
考える力がない。自分のことばっかり考え
とるやないか。マスコミと一緒よ。役人が
悪いんやなしに偏差修が悪いんだから
あんなものが活躍する世の中を作っちまっ
た。これは日本の不幸をね教育見たら
分かるやろ。大失敗やないか。民主主義の
定義は知っとるかな?民主主義の定義は
交代性やろ。権力の交代性。
これが民主義なんだからマスコミは反権力ないといかんな。マスコミがそいつをアかんといかん。ところがあれ真権力やね。権力者と一緒になって悪いことばっかりするよね。マスコミというのは。あれ民主義知らんの?
財務省のデモとかもなんかマスコミがあんまり報道しないっていうのがそういう話題になってたりするんですよ。
あれはもう財務省の味方なんよね。マスコミなんてよく国有内地とか名古屋だったの名古屋のそばとかな。
ああいうところを全部自分のところに
払い下げさせてそこに本社持っとるじゃん
。で、ああいうことやるもんで
ねっちまうんよね。権力を利用
する校長の偏差修催のお話で偏差も試験を
突破するために努力した結果なったものな
のかなって個人的に思ったんですけど。
うん。その試験が悪いんじゃん。得意
育体育の3つが教育やね。修催地域の試験
は突破しとるわね。得意育と体育は試験
なんかね、1番大事なのは得意なんだ。
人間性が高くないと権力者になってはいか
んのや。だから論語でも何でも見るとまず
就身を納める。これが得意ね。それを全然
やってないじゃん。大体得って何か知っ
とるかな。得意だと言うけどマスコミは
得意反対なんて言うとったんやけどあの時
に得ってなんか知らんよね。だから常に
自分が何を言るか分かっとらんのに
決めつけるんだ。アメリカの都合のいい
ようにやっていくというのが新聞の
マスコミの特徴よね。校長が試験作るとし
たら今のままでもいいと思うんですけど
とんでもない。今のあれはチークになって
ないじゃないね。の目的は思考力を作る
こと。論理的思考能力。正しく考える力を
つけようって言っとんだ。この頃なんとか
AIでそれを教育に取り入れようとしとる
じゃん。コンピューターに考えさせりゃ
ええって言っとるんや。あんなもの採用し
たら人間自分が考える力要請されんじゃん
。だから1丁前円になったらなんとかAI
は使ってもよろしいがそれまでは使っては
いかんということにせねや。それをAIを
使わせるのがいいことなんだという。
マスコミはそう言っとるやん。だからダメ
なんよ。あいつらなトレーニングという
意識がない
。すいません。
育のお話になっちゃったんですけど、得意と体育で例えばどういう試験を作ったらいいみたいなのってありますか?
特育はね、人間性が高いって言うとよくその意味が分からんと思うんよ。だけど例えば頑張るとか善であるとかいうのも人間性が高いんそやね。
だから得意をしっかりやっておけば、
例えば労働力としても頑張って一生懸命
やって成果を上げるという、そういう人間
が人間性が高いんや。得意この成功者や。
今口で言って何ができるね。あれはいけ
ません。右が通行しましょう。人に悪い
ことをしていけません。そんなもの何にも
身につかんよね。頭の中にあったってダめ
だ。行動できなけれ。それよりもあれを
やらした方がええ体育を体育はもう頑張ら
んといかのばっかりやないか。だから
頑張る力がつく。これ人間性が高いんだ。
正しくがつけばもっと高いんだ。だから
正しく頑張る能力。これを身につけ
させようよ。もういわゆる我々が今いいと
言っとるチークなんか全然問題にならんよ
ね。あんも頑張る力つかんやん。
覚える力を一生懸命つけて、俺で優秀であるって言うんやからあめや。日本の血管よね。ああいうものは
どういう試験だったら良くなりますかね。
今ね、いいテレ見てらNHK
の子供向けの番組でね、いわゆる共容番組というか、教育番組っていうか、あれものすごいええよ。昔のわ説明するだけのもんじゃなみんなで考えてみようって言うんや。答えは来週答え出さんのや。
[音楽]
次の週に答えが出てくるんや。それまた自分で考えろって。あれを繰り返せばええんじゃん。学校の授業もそういう事業にしなくっちゃ。文化系的事業ではだめよ。
体育はどうですか?
体育は何を養ったらいいと思う?
集中力。
集中力なんやな。だから集中力が絶対に必要なことをやらせたらええ。例えば剣玉よ。で、剣玉を体育としてやったらええんだ。
今あれスポーツとしてやっとるから意味
ないじゃん。け玉は体育としてやれば
素晴らしい効果を発揮する。スポーツとし
てやってもそれでけ玉がうまくなってお
しまいや。そういう風に集中力に焦点を
当ててともかく退屈は集中力を養うもんな
んだとしてやればええんだ。だどんなこと
をやってもスポーツでもスポーツで体育が
やれる。そういう教え方をすればいい。
野球やっても野球でトンネルするやつが
おるじゃん。あいつにうまく取れる方法を
教えてやるんだ。トンネルするやつ見てる
とね。あ、すぐ分かるよ。弾を怖がっとる
んや。だからその玉から逃げようとする
もんで当然取れんのや。そうじゃなしに玉
に集中しない。グローブをその玉の筋に
持ってきてそこに取るんだから。グローブ
を持った手ここに集中するんだ。そそ
たまに集中してないもんで。怖くないん
まずね。で、手はその玉が取れるような
ところにグローブを持っていくんだ。だ
から取れる。どこに集中するかということ
をどんどんどんどん覚えていく。みんな
動くもの運動でも何でもそうやけど大体
筋肉で動かすからどこの筋肉に集中するか
でええん。そうするとね不思議なごとに
今度は手に集中しなくても栄えようになっ
てくるんよ。今度は肩に集中するんや。肩
を中心としてグローブが動いとるやろ。
なんかその肩を安定させたらええ、玉筋に
グローブが安定してうまく取れる。で、
それで完璧に取れるようになったら今度は
単電に集中するんだね。みんな丹電を中心
として行動しとるわけやから。そ、もっと
うまく取れるような、もう名人の息に
達するわけね。そうやって集中力で
どんどんどんどんうくなっていく。名人に
なってレベルが上がっていく。
その集中力は今なんだ?長ら族ばっかりに
なっとるやないかな。何々しながらこれを
する。あれはやめんとね。さっきちょっと
出てきた武士の娘という論を習う場面が
あるんや。先生が1人いてで武士の娘が
こっちに座っててずっと教えてもらっとる
んやね。で、なんかの星にちょっと動い
たって言うんや。そしたら先生が集中力が
なくなった。だから授業はもうやらない
言うて帰っちまうという場面が出てくるわ
。それぐらい集中力を大事にしたんやな。
集中してないとダメなんや。正しくでき
ないから。今のは特にマスコミがあるもん
でなあ。テレビがなりながらなんかやっ
とるわね。音楽聞きながらなんかやっとる
で。最後には音楽聞いたらうまくできる
ようになっちまうんやね。あれはもう
リズムを取ってもらっとるわけやけどね。
けどそういう情けない状態なんよ。
大学の入手とかに体育があったら改善されたりするんですかね?
どうやってやるか。あれはもう試験でやるもんやないもんで。こういうことやった人がおるよ。地方議員やっててね。地方で有名な人だからみんなそこの秘書になりたいわけね。将来議員を狙うような連中が。で、その希望者が例えば
人集まってきたと。そん中から1
人を選ぼうと。で、その時に彼のやった
試験はね、みんな靴下を脱げと。で、靴下
を脱いで1人ずつ片足でその靴下立った
まま靴下履いてみでそれが開けるまで
ストップウォッチで測っとく。開けるまで
によめえたりひっくり返ったりしないかを
見る。そでうまくるやつを採用したという
のがある。これ暗証安定してなければ進歩
しないということなん。だから今は議員に
なりたいと言ってきたってまだ素人やから
うまくできやしない。彼らが進歩して立派
な秘書になるわけやろから進歩するかどう
かをそれでテストしとるんや。ちゃんと
安定するかどうかで。これも授況の利用。
暗証強景という言葉の利用やね。それ
ぐらい安定が大事からその安定するために
集中力がいる。どっかに集中すると本当に
安定するんよ。そういう練習をしとかには
です。
[音楽]